Now let's remember, the whole concept of convolution and
gradients, again, recall that convolution is basically taking our,
kernel, involving with the input to get a new image.
So this is [INAUDIBLE] of convolution, we'll now need to ask the question,
what happens if I take this convolution formulation and
just do a derivative of this in x, of course, we would do it separately for y,
if I was to do a, derivative of this,
basically means that I would have derivative of the convolution.
To help us, let say if D is the kernel to compute the derivatives, and
H is the kernel for smoothing.
So basically, what we're kind of saying is,
dell of the x could actually become now a operation because we
have actually represented basically that as a kernel to compute derivatives, and
H is a kernel, for smoothing, we can rewrite this formulation as, so
again, if D and H are known, we could basically now define the derivative and
smoothing operation as one formulation, D, convolved with, H convolved with F.
Of course, remembering our understanding of the basic properties of convolution,
we could actually do a derivative of the kernel, and then
just apply the convolution of the kernel itself directly to the input image.
So we could actually now not just have to do, this process and
then come up with the derivative, I could take any kernel and
keep it in my storage as a new kernel that basically has a derivative itself,
and use that and apply directly to the image.
So this actually becomes an interesting way of looking at things, and
again, it's widely used in how we do types of image processing,
types of techniques to extract gradients.